nous
et
bonsoir bonsoir à tous alors je pense
que la plupart d'entre vous vous avez la
chance de ne pas encore trop connaître
l'hôpital mais si je vous demande aux
uns et aux autres
à quoi sert un hôpital et pourquoi c'est
faire peser de répondre c'est un endroit
où il ya des malades qui sont soignés
par des médecins dont tu te rends telle
mesure vous aurez raison
mais ce que je veux vous dire c'est que
dans le passé l'hôpital n'a pas du tout
été inventé pour ça et dans le passé il
n'a jamais été quelque chose où il y
avait des médecins
il ya des médecins que depuis très peu
de temps à l'hôpital et puis même des
malades y en a qui depuis aussi très peu
de temps je raconte ça brièvement nous
sommes au moyen âge on vient de créer
l'hôpital c'est l'église qu'ils créent
et ali mais tous les moyens en disant
nous allons nous occuper des étrangers
des gens qui passent des pèlerins qui
sillonne la france des indigents qu'il
faut bien coucher le soir mais les
malades
non on ne sait pas très bien ce que
c'est dans le haut moyen âge
donc c'est un hôtel c'est un hôtel dieu
mais c'est un hôtel au sens que vous
savez ce qu est un hôtel aujourd'hui et
dans cet hôtel il n'y a pas de médecin
on peut imaginer l'hôtel dieu de paris
par exemple il est situé au moyen-âge
sur le square charlemagne
c'est une grande salle voûtée où il ya
des lits des gens qui sont dans les lits
sont 3 4 par lee à peu près tête bêche
il ya une bonne place celle qui peut
regarder le crucifix quête aux fondus au
fond de la salle parce que c'est du
crucifix que éventuellement peut venir
le salut parce qu'il y en a pas d'autre
les seules personnes qui sont là sont
les soeurs les soeurs augustines
alors elle donne des petits médicaments
on appelle ça des médicaments mais c'est
rien du tout c'est c'est s'aider des
gris gris
il ya un barbier qui passe de temps en
temps pour pour gratter les plaies pour
amputer de temps en temps mais c'est
tout y a rien donc l'hôtel-dieu ccsa
puis la france est un pays rural mais un
pays rural qui rapidement va ce peuple
et à la fin du moyen-âge ya beaucoup de
bons la population française est
multiplié par trois en deux siècles
c'est considérable alors ça entraîne des
famines et puissante reine que les gens
soient obligés de se réfugier dans les
villes donc une urbanisation il ya des
tas de gens dans les villes et dans les
villes quand les gens sont présents ça
permet les épidémies parce que pour
avoir des épidémies il faut que des gens
rassemblés
quand les gens sont curieux la campagne
a pas d'épidémie mais quand ils sont
dans une ville il ya des belles épidémie
alors ça fait quand même des gens qui
sont dangereux parce qu'ils sont
contagieux on comprend quand même que la
peste c'est contagieux
et puis il ya des miséreux alors malade
miséreux c'est pas clair dans l'esprit
des gens n'est pas très claire alors les
malades miséreux les miséreux ils sont
dangereux aussi pourquoi ils sont
dangereux la mairie parce qu'ils
deviennent des truands et les truands et
bien ils attaquent le bourgeois est ce
que veulent pouvoir public c'est qu'il
n'y ait pas de problèmes dans les rues
de paris
donc pas de pagnol paris c'est simple on
va prendre tous ces gens là et on va les
mettre dans un endroit une gêne aux
personnes les cottages yeux et les
miséreux et il faut créer donc des
dacquois pas des hôpitaux c'est bien
l'hôpital pour mettre tous ces gens là
et louis xiv le cerenicimo 14 créé trois
hôpitaux à paris bicêtre pour les hommes
allaient tous les truands up à bicêtre
linceul prière pour les femmes allaient
toutes les [ __ ]
on se retrouve à la salpêtrière et et
quand même pour les militaires qui sont
amputés et les pauvres et qui montrent
leur moignon dans les rues de paris
eh bien il faut créer un bel hôtel c'est
l'hôtel des invalides qui existe
toujours ses trois hôpitaux existe
toujours aujourd'hui toujours
aujourd'hui ils ont été créés par louis
xiv
ça va vous permettre vous parlais tout à
l'heure de l'évolution de l'hôpital de
même ils sont toujours là aujourd'hui
alors les choses évoluent quand même un
petit peu on fait un petit saut dans le
temps donc l'hôpital est une prison
l'hôpital est une prison arrive la
révolution française la révolution
française elle déteste l'hôpital lt test
orbital lorsque si les curés c'est les
bonnes soeurs et carnot vire tous les
curés toutes les bonnes soeurs qui sont
dans les hôpitaux de cas plus personne
et un poids de médecins déjà maintenant
il ya plus d'infirmières soignantes et
puis saint-just à la convention
nationale dit nous avec la révolution
nous allons supprimer la misère donc il
n'y aura plus de maladies et s'il ya
plus de maladies a plus besoin le plus
tôt nous allons vendre des hôpitaux et
on vend à la pendant la convention
nationale révolution française tous les
hôpitaux comme biens nationaux en
assignats si bien qu'à la fin de la
convention
il ya plus un hôpital en france il n'y a
plus non plus de médecins je n'avais pas
avant dans les hôpitaux lyonnais plus du
tout là pour le coup car la loi le
chapelet fait qu il n'y a plus de
médecin du tout en france la situation
malheureusement pour ce que pensait
saint-just il en a perdu la tête le
pauvre est bien fait qu' il ya encore
des maladies et encore des blessés est
aussi plus où les mettre
parce qu'il ya plus depuis tôt alors là
je lui ai dit qu'il fallait des hommes à
poigne pour réformer l'hôpital et pour
créer des hôpitaux y arrive mais sur est
un poignant c'est le petit caporal
il s'appelle bonaparte il est premier
consul holding a pu lhopiteau du qu il
faut des hôpitaux en france et il fait
créer des hôpitaux
il donne la responsabilité hôpitaux aux
maires de toutes les communes d'avoir un
hôpital il en est responsable
il doit en assumer le fonctionnement et
il n'est pas question que ça se passe
autrement
paf je vous signale qu'aujourd'hui
encore le maire est responsable de
l'hôpital de sa ville
pioli dit monsieur préconçues il n'y a
pas de médecins y en a jamais eu
remarqué mais y en a pas il faut les
médecins les hôpitaux du premier consul
et ben c'est très bien je vais créer un
concours concours républicain les
meilleurs l'internât des hôpitaux et
l'externe les hôpitaux est créé par un
arrêté bien entendu de vente aux en dise
et créant l'internât avec un concours
il va attirer les meilleurs vers
l'hôpital et ce faisant et sans s'en
rendre compte
par cet élitisme un peu fort ce n'est
tout à fait républicain est tout à fait
la polonia pour tout dire eh bien il va
finir
pas amené les médecins à l'hôpital ce
christ ne s'était jamais produit jusque
là et les médecins vont venir à
l'hôpital et ils vont trouver quoi
l'hôpital non pas des malades ou dia pas
tellement tellement magique des malades
il ya surtout des miséreux c'est affreux
la misère est horrible mais parmi eux il
ya dix ans quand même parmi tous ces
livres il ya des malades alors les
médecins vont en profiter
ils vont décrire toutes les maladies
pour le 10ème siècle les chirurgiens
vont en profiter et ils vont se faire
entre guillemets la main le matin à
l'hôpital
en inventant toutes les grandes
opérations de résection clisson tout
inventé pendant le 2e siècle
vous avez dit remet alors et les riches
alors ils sont pas malades ainsi les
riches y sont malades mais ils sont
opérés chez eux ils soient opérés chez
eux
l'après-midi par les grands patrons qui
vont les opérer à domicile alors quand
elle arrive à l'écran patron avec leurs
trousses sous le bras vous repérez la
maîtresse de maison
qu'est ce qu'ils disent bendis m'a
écouté une faudrait un plan du rhin pour
pouvoir faire l'opération
votre livre est trop mou le professeur
n'y a pas de problème on a le billard et
on va donc vous mettre sur le billard et
je suis sûr que les uns et les autres
vous dit encore aujourd'hui il est passé
sur le billard
eh ben ça vient de là tout simplement ça
vient de l'époque où les grands
chirurgiens allait opérer à domicile et
donc pendant tout le 19e et le début du
20e siècle
les pauvres sont à l'hôpital et les
riches se font si soignée soit chez eux
soit dans quelques petites clinique
huppée où l'église a remis des billes et
a remis des religieuses pour être
infirmière il va se produire une
troisième révolution dans l'évolution
l'hôpital qui est dans cette situation
est quand même un peu triste ou
l'hôpital n'occuper que par des pauvres
gens ou les médecins viennent que le
matin et finalement seule interne reste
l'après midi et la nuit et où
l'enseignement se fait à la faculté mais
pas vraiment à l'hôpital il faut faire
une révolution elle a lieu elle a lieu
elle est liée à un grand médecin qui
s'appelait robert debré
qui invente le centre hospitalo
universitaires en demandant à tous les
grands patrons de rester plein temps à
l'hôpital de rester tout le temps à
l'hôpital
ça c'est une révolution je peux vous
dire parce que niveau où ils peuvent
plus aller opérer leurs malades sur le
billard l'après midi c'est fini ils sont
obligés de rester à l'hôpital il faut
une poigne pour faire passer ça comme il
y avait eu louis xiv comme il y avait eu
bonaparte la troisième poigne c'est de
gaulle de gaulle fait passer la réforme
hospitalo universitaire en 1958 et ce
faisant il crée un nouveau monde
hospitalier qui ont presque 50 ans enfin
même même moins en quarante ans va
amener le système hospitalier français
sans doute un des meilleurs du monde
avec en particulier la possibilité
d'avoir un système à la fois juste très
très bon sur le plan technique et très
très bien répartis sur l'ensemble du
territoire avec énormément d'hôpitaux
dans presque toutes les villes de france
à tel point que la classification des
oms avait mis la france en l'an 2000
comme le premier système de santé du
monde il y réussit très bien ce que vous
nous racontez la présence fabiani sapa
là vous avez bien l'hôpital depuis le
moyen-âge pour arriver aux meilleurs
systèmes de santé
ouais m'enfin vous lisez les journaux
vous voyez bien que l'hôpital est en
train de subir un tremblement des
infirmières se suicide
les médecins sont pas contents se
mettent en grève les gens à l'hôpital
estime qu' ils ne sont pas aussi bien
soigné qu'il pourrait l'être et ainsi de
suite et instituts et qu'est ce qui se
passe dans l'hôpital vous savez
l'évolution des grandes institutions
comme celle-là c'est à l'abbaye aux
grands loi darwinienne c'est à dire qu'
il va se produire des évolutions des
changements ou bien on va être capable
de s'adapter et on va perdurer
ou bien on ne le sera pas et le système
disparaîtra et qu'est ce qui se passe
actuellement est bien des changements
considérables
le premier changement tout le monde le
sait c'est que la santé coûte de plus en
plus
d'abord parce qu'il faut des gens pour
le faire marcher et que les salaires
c'est quand même
comme dans toutes les entreprises 70% du
budget et que s'il n'ya pas
d'infirmières ça marche pas si ya pas de
médecin ça marche pas bon donc il ya le
la masse salariale mais il ya aussi
toutes ses machines ses matchs il a
diagnostiqué ces machines à soigner qui
deviennent de plus en plus sophistiquées
avec des plateaux techniques de plus en
plus sophistiqués alors là faut être
clair et je vais l'être puisque je suis
là pour ça on ne pourra plus garder dans
toutes les petites villes de france
son petit hôpital tellement sympathique
avec le directeur qu'on connaît pas ce
qu'il fait son marché avec nous le
dimanche avec les médecins qu'on connaît
très bien sait les médecins en même
temps qui viennent sur les visites la
premi dans c'est fini il n'y aura plus
tous ces petits hôpitaux parce qu'on en
a pas des moyens les grands pays
industriels se trouvent actuellement à
12 % de leur pib en soins de santé
on sait très bien qu'on peut pas aller
beaucoup plus loin donc il va faire
faire des sacrifices des sacrifices en
nombre de lits vous me dire bah oui mais
les malades c'est bien gentil mais où
est ce que vous allez m et où est ce
qu'on va les mettre c'est une bonne
question
il ya des choses qui sont en train de se
produire actuellement qui vont
rapidement donner des solutions au
problème ça s'appelle la télémédecine et
on est capable maintenant de soigner
même de diagnostic et de plus en plus de
choses les malades restant chez eux
grâce à la télémédecine
il était métier train de se développer
une vitesse incroyable
alors bien sûr c'est pas encore entré
dans les règles de toutes vos vies aux
uns et aux autres
mais elle est déjà rentré dans dans bien
des systèmes notamment tous les gens qui
habitent les villes iep personnes âgées
qui habitent dans une maison de
convalescence ou dans une maison de
retraite
on peut pas les faire venir à l'hôpital
sans arrêt pour faire des examens non on
va faire les examens dans la maison de
retraite et tout ça s'est transmis par
vidéo
le médecin reste à l'hôpital et il fait
le diagnostic est ça qu on le veuille ou
non même si c'est peut-être un petit peu
moins bien sur le plan du contact humain
et bien c'est ce qui va se passer dans
les années qui viennent
et puis autre élément qui va entrer dans
la balance
il est clair c'est l'arrivée de
l'intelligence artificielle
l'intelligence artificielle elle est là
elle existe
et actuellement ses machines ses
machines ses robots que j'utilise par
exemple dans ma salle d'opération on
opère maintenant le chirurgien par trois
petits trous on va faire des opérations
sur le coeur on nous on pourrait opérer
de notre bureau ou pourrait même repéré
deux de notre cuisine
ça n'a pas d'importance parce que le
robot est bien on voit par un système 3d
absolument extraordinaire ce qu'il est
en train de faire et il est piloté à
distance et entre eux
le chirurgien et les instruments qu'est
ce qu'il ya il ya un outil que kiki en
train de révolutionner le monde qui
s'appelle l'ordinateur admettons que
j'ai trop bu et que je tremble comme ça
pour faire mon opération
le robot reprends mon geste et le fait
parfaitement lisse est parfaitement sain
le coeur quand je perds tous les jours
il bat ou mlc en béton d'opérer un coeur
qui bat parce que ça surtout le temps
d'un très bien et bien l'ordinateur fait
une image virtuelle d'un coeur arrêté et
il met tous mes instruments absolument
en phase avec le coeur qui bat et moi
j'ai l'impression de perret sur un coeur
arrêté et ainsi de suite
autrement dit nous sommes en train je
parle des chirurgiens de vivre une vraie
révolution
mais l'intelligence artificielle va plus
loin le scanner qui sort de la nouvelle
machine la diagnostiquer et bien
l'intelligence artificielle porte un
diagnostic sur ce scanner supérieur à
celui qu'aurait les dix meilleurs
radiologues du monde réunit donc
toussaint je sais pas encore comment ça
va évoluer parce que c'est difficile
d'être prédictif dans ce genre de choses
mais je peux vous dire que l'hôpital tel
que nous le connaissons encore
aujourd'hui même si je suis pas dans le
pire des hôpitaux pompidou c'est le plus
moderne des hôpitaux de paris
eh bien il est déjà obsolète par rapport
à ce que va être demain les jets demain
l'hôpital que vous vous allez connaître
et que vous vous allez être obligés de
gérer parce que l'hôpital vous l'avez
compris c'est un bien commun
c'est un bien commun de toutes les
générations et il va falloir que nous
trouvions les solutions d'abord pour les
garder d'abord pour les rendre plus
performants d'abord pour que les malades
n'y ait pas trop
finalement on est mieux soigné chez soi
si on peut l'être puis à l'hôpital dans
la mesure du possible en dehors des cas
extrêmement extrêmement graves qui
nécessitent être pris 24 heures sur 24
et cet hôpital là avec les petites
pistes que je viens de vous donner
eh bien il va falloir l'imaginer et si
nous ne l'imaginons pas assez bien et
assez vite et bien comme l'homme de
néandertal nous disparaîtrons
c'était ce que j'avais à vous dire
[Applaudissements]